thank you to the chief Constable for
giving us the briefing today and
bringing us up to speed with the
investigation I think that it is so
important and moments like this that we
stand United and we do stand here United
as one voice in our condemnation against
this horrific attack on a police officer
someone who's part of our community and
I think that the most powerful message
that we as political leaders can start
can do is to stand with the chief
Constable today at a stand with the
police service and to say this is not
good enough this is an attack on all of
us this is an attack on our community
and finally the only other thing that I
would want to say today is that my
thoughts very much remain with the
family these are this is a family who
are going through as Roma these are a
family that are sitting at a hospital
bed this is a son who's witnessed his
father being attacked in this callous
way so my thoughts are very very much
with John's family today
on behalf of my own party I would like
to extend to the chief constable and his
colleagues and of course to DCI John
Caldwell and his family our thoughts and
prayers at this time we continue to pray
that DCI Caldwell will will make a good
recovery from the terrible injuries that
he has sustained and also to say to all
of those very brave men and women who
each day serve our community so
Faithfully with and with great courage
that we all stand with you you have our
continued support
but words are good we also need to
ensure that the psni has the resource
that it needs to carry out its job
effectively and we will work together as
parties engaging with the government to
ensure that that resource is made
available to the chief constable and to
the psni and we hope to have the
opportunity to do that in the coming
days
I would also say to the the evil people
who carried out this penis attack and to
their organization you are not the
future of this place we stand against
you
the murder of police officers and the
attempted killing of those who serve our
communities in Northern Ireland was
unacceptable when my cousin was the
first ruc officer to be murdered by the
IRA in 1970.
loyalists have also killed police
officers
it was never acceptable and it is not
acceptable now it will not be tolerated
and we stand Foursquare with the police
to ensure that those who have been
responsible for this attack are brought
to Justice and that they do not dictate
how this place moves forward for the
future
today all five physical parties in
Northern Ireland are standing shoulder
to shoulder with the chief constable and
indeed all of the brave men and women of
the Police Service of Northern Ireland
all five parties are utterly United and
rejecting terrorism and standing up for
the root of law of Deborah Herrick
principles that's the only foundation on
which this Society can work we are
determined that those responsible will
be brought to Justice and indeed that
the police have the resources that they
need to do their job properly
the immediate family of John Caldwell
Caldwell are very much in our thoughts
as are the wider police family
themselves we are very conscious of the
impact and something like this can have
upon police morale I think it's equally
important to stress that what we're
hearing back from the front line is a
determination and a resilience to do
their job on behalf of the community and
they have our full support in that
regard
the attack on John the attack on uh John
Colwell was an attack on a husband it
was an attack on a father it was an
attack on the community of oma it was an
attack on our society it's an attack on
our children it's an attack on our peace
a hard one piece uh and it's an attack
on the Belfast Good Friday agreement
but it will not work because we do Stand
United and as the leader of the Ulster
Union's party I stand with the leader of
shin Fein of the dup of the elan's party
of the sdlp and we tell these people out
there who through word or deed who try
to undermine our peace it will not work
because we will stand United and we will
ask our society to do similar to raise
their voices against these people and
say you do not belong here
what you stand for does not represent us
you will not undermine what we have
achieved in the last 25 years for your
own vile depraved ends
we will overcome this and I will stand
with the chief constable and with his
psni officers to ensure that is the case
well first of first of all it's
important that we send our love and
support to John and his family and also
our solidarity to every single psma
officer who's at work today and we want
to let them know that they are part of
our community and that they have all of
our support the people standing here are
the representatives of the people those
people who carried out this attack
represent nobody they will achieve
nothing they think they're at war with
the British state they're at war with
the people of Ireland and from my
perspective that is a battle that they
will never ever win
terms of job called well
the whole thing
yesterday
you today you're here together for uh
well certainly in relation to protective
equipment
it's been something that's free I'm
assuming not he remains seriously
injured in result of the the shooting
that he suffered and as I said earlier
it remains heavily sedated in hospital
and in terms of what's next I mean I
think it's important that we remain
United I think it's important that we
continue to send a United message to
wader Society we this year celebrate 25
years over a good Friday agreement and
so much that's been achieved over those
past 25 years our society has been
completely transformed and we're not
going to allow anybody to reverse any of
that progress that's been made so that's
why it's very important that we do put
across today that this is an attack on
the community this is an attack on all
of us and this is an attack that none of
us will ever tolerate
I think it's important that um we all
redouble our efforts to get to the
solutions we need politically to move
Northern Ireland forward but we are
determined all of us to ensure that
is clear violence is no place in our
society the evil deed done to John
Caldwell and to those around him
is unacceptable will not be tolerated
and these people will not have their way
we're all going to stress the importance
of giving the Police Service North down
in the resources and the tools they can
do the job in terms of keeping the
community safe
as a result
we'll take from the image of you being
flanked by
well I think it's hugely important I was
out personally last night at Oma police
station I was out at the scene of the
shooting and speaking to both detectives
neighborhood officers some of the
officers carrying out searches with sort
of a real sense of pace and frenzy
yesterday but clearly we are a tough and
resilient bunch of people that are
committed to protecting communities but
all the conversations that I was having
yesterday and indeed this morning do not
underestimate The Importance of Being
joined by political leaders to say that
policing is a key part of the fabric of
society to keep us all safe our officers
and staff are drawn from communities
it's the whole basis of which society
works and I don't think we should owners
underestimate for one minute the
symbolism and importance of standing
together today to send out as people
have said this morning a very clear and
firm message that there was no place for
these Twisted beliefs and no place for
attacks on people that are going about
their daily lives and work as public
servants
hmm
would you like to say
what you dealt with
yeah well certainly what happens next in
terms of local and and National politics
is is a matter for politicians from the
point of view as the head of this
organization we would welcome support to
keep us at the level of offices we've
got but actually to take us back to
where we were a year ago we've rehearsed
a number of times where over 300
officers down as we speak we've got
enough people at the moment to continue
the pace and momentum of this
investigation but in a year's time if
our budgetary situation isn't addressed
I remember being far more concerned
about our resilience and capability to
keep up the pressure against the
terrorist organizations to keep all of
our community safe and we're an active
dialogue both with local and GB
political leaders I think it's worth
saying that um security is also a
Westminster responsibility just as his
devolved security is still dealt with by
Westminster and therefore we do look to
the UK government to honor the
commitments they gave a new decade new
approach to help with the funding of the
recruitment of police officers we heard
from the policing board this morning
they continued to set they continue to
meet they have a political
responsibility as well and continue to
exercise that function so we don't have
a vacuum in the sense that the resource
can be found must be found and the
police must have what they need not only
to tackle terrorism but to continue to
keep people safe across our communities
can I just say on that at one point look
it's clear we have differences of
opinion about how and when we get storm
and back up and run I'd like to see it
back tomorrow and hopefully we'll
resolve all of that but the one thing
that unites us today is our absolute
revulsion about what happened uh to John
Caldwell and our determination not to be
dragged back we will keep going forward
political differences aside we are not
going to be put off the course that
we're on
Stephen Murphy Sky News Chief Constable
uh given that we've heard Rumblings of
discontent and potential violence among
loyalist paramuses for quite some time
now or do you have any concerns of any
potential retaliatory action from those
groupings or indeed more dissident
Republican activity ahead of the Good
Friday past women's anniversary
well firstly in terms of uh dissident
Republican activity awful as this
outrage is we are running operations
most days around the clock to try and
frustrate and disrupt active Planning by
a small number of dissident Republicans
to attack police officers going about
their work or indeed in in their daily
lives so that is something that has been
happening before these awful events and
sadly will continue beyond in terms of
reaction from royalism we have obviously
been keeping our eyes and ears open and
we're doing stuff behind the scenes
prudently to make sure that we're aware
of sentiment and and chatter if you like
but we don't see any sense of any
backlash at the moment
threat against police officers is
increasing in Northern Ireland
well the threat level at the moment was
changed last spring so it always has
stood the case that an attack was highly
likely sadly on this occasion the
terrorists have have struck home and
have seriously injured one of our
colleagues we have dealt with a number
of plots recently some of which have
come to fruition before Christmas which
fortunately haven't seen police officers
killed or seriously injured but we are
working around the clock to try and
disrupt the terrorist activity we remain
concerned at the tempo and we're working
closely with other security Partners to
make sure we remain on the front foot
and I think the symbolism today the loud
voice of condemnation should reached
into communities and isolate these small
number of people that are going about
their evil ways there is no place for
this
I think the resource issue has been well
exercised and I think for today Rebecca
what we're all focused on is the united
front what we're all focused on is
saying no to this activity what we're
all focusing on is making sure that gets
across loud and clear we've had some
more conversations today around
resources we will carry that
conversation forward it's very very
important we're all entitled to have
good Community Place and we're all
entitled to have that in our in our
communities every day being part of the
community because these are police
officers are people who live in our
communities who go to football grounds
who train youngsters who are part of
everyday life so it's really really
important that that's property resourced
so for us I think today it's about the
united front but let's continue the
conversation around resources and if I
could say on behalf of the the outgoing
Justice Minister and Naomi long
um the issue around the Justice Budget
on D police resources has been something
that has been flagged in relation to the
this year's uh budget and it's important
to stress that next year's budget has
not yet been struck either by a DeWalt
executive or by the Northern Ireland
office so clearly there is a job of work
to be done in terms of lobbying to make
sure that the importance of this aspect
is fully understood by those who will
eventually take the decision whether
it's in Belfast or in London and indeed
the issue was raised during the budget
debate in the House of Commons with the
Northern Ireland office about the need
to support the police about the need to
honor commitments made by the UK
government in new decade new approach
and we will continue to press that with
the government
yes thank you well I personally spoke to
the guard commissioner Drew Harris
yesterday he has been very forthright in
both his personal support because from
his previous career he knows John weld
so there's a slightly different
dimension to this but our absolute
Assurance he has stepped up Patrols in
the immediate border area to complement
some of the activity that we're doing at
the moment but I have complete assurance
that he stands strongly with us and his
forthright and his condemnation both of
this attack but also making sure that
his officers are working in lockstep
with us to try and frustrate further
outrage and make sure we bring the
people that have committed this attack
to Justice
thank you